[Music]
it's the last weekend to drive through
the Tropicana exit before ndot's major
Tropicana project causes some major
changes this week Victoria Saha spoke
with ndot and explains
Tropicana will be turning into Tropicana
Southern Nevada Department of
Transportation takes down half of the
Tropicana flyover heading into the strip
right now it's too low it doesn't beat
Federal height requirements Justin
Hopkins with ndot says this project
won't finish until 2025. he says the
Tropicana overpass on I-15 often gets
hit by large trucks and once that's
fixed there are more lanes that will be
added so it's going to go from three
lanes in both directions to four lanes
in both directions all the way from Las
Vegas Boulevard to Valley View we're
also making a number of pedestrian
improvements including taking the
sidewalks from five feet to 10 new
lighting making it more pedestrian
friendly when it comes to events
Allegiant and T-Mobile Arena the
Tropicana project will include closing
the I-15 both ways on Tropicana are for
eight days starting January 22nd through
the 30th it will also include a
three-day closure of I-15 in both
directions between Flamingo and Russell
starting January 27th ndot says they
have come out with an app that you can
download to keep up to date with
construction and to find another way to
get around the cutoff for the last car
to travel through the Tropicana exit
will be Tuesday at 11 PM Victoria Saha 8
news now now as Victoria mentioned this
whole project will last until 2025 and
will cost over 300 million dollars
Victoria also asked how this would
affect the Super Bowl coming to town
next year ndot says they have plans in
place to help traffic but those will be
released closer to the big game